-Whoo!
-John Stamos, you are the best.
We have a lot to talk about.
It is out.
It is out today officially.
Your memoir.
We talked about this
-Yes.
-And now it's finally out.
We can discuss things.
-We can talk about
so many things
-We can talk about it.
So first of all,
happy belated birthday.
-Thank you.
-How old?
-42.
-Wow. Unbelievable.
Congratulations.
-I turned 60.
-60-years-old.
That doesn't make sense to me.
-Me either.
-It doesn't make sense to you.
-No, it's good.
-I got to say, this book,
by the way, congratulations on
the reviews coming in.
You're getting
a lot of praise
because you're very honest
about things.
Your sobriety, your divorce.
-Yeah.
-It's got to be pretty tough
to write a memoir in some way.
-I didn't -- I didn't -- I never
thought I'd write a book.
It was the last thing
on my mind.
And, you know,
they just kept asking.
And then I was
a father at 55.
And then, you know,
Bob Saget died.
And so I thought, well, maybe
I do have something to say.
And so I started writing it.
And as I was writing it,
I discovered my story.
I decided to write
the two hardest chapters.
The first chapter
was terrible,
my lowest point
where I got a DUI
and my five stages of grief
there were like sex,
drugs, alcohol.
And then I wrote
the second hardest,
which I thought was
the Bob Saget chapter.
And by then I was --
my five stages of grief
were health and therapy
and family.
And it was, you know,
it was trying
to figure out how I got there,
but it was a good journey.
-Amazing stories
throughout the whole thing.
I mean, what a crazy career
that you've had.
-I didn't think so,
and then I started writing
I was like, you know,
the Beach Boys.
But I wanted to find
relatable issues.
You know, I was bullied
and that's, you know?
-That's the part
I love that stuff.
But I also love, I mean,
I'm a fan
from "General Hospital."
-Oh, you are?
-Oh, yeah. I mean...
-They wanted a street urchin,
you know, from New York.
I'd never been to New York.
I didn't know what
a street urchin was.
-So the audition
for "General Hospital."
-It's like a street guy,
Blackie Parrish, you know?
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah, and I didn't --
I went to the library
to see what street urchin was.
-Street urchin.
-But I figured,
you know, I was in --
I loved Travolta
like you did, right?
[ Chuckles ]
-I can't believe...
[ Both imitating John Travolta ]
-What's the matter with me?
What's the matter with you?
-What's the matter with you?
Oh.
He's the best, right?
-He's the...
-I loved it.
So I figured
I need a walk,
you know, for
the Blackie character.
And I drove around Hollywood,
and I went to this one,
Santa Monica Boulevard.
I thought, this looks
like New York, right?
I borrowed my mom's
leather jacket,
and it was kind of puffy,
you know, I thought it was cool,
but it was like this long,
puffy jacket.
I had feathered hair,
sun in it like you,
sun into my hair.
Did you put sun in?
-Yes, I did.
I was a Beach Boy.
-Sun in. Why not, man?
-Yeah, yeah.
And so I walked here --
And I figured if I put --
Help me.
Because remember
when he had...
But I didn't --
I wasn't very good.
But you know like...
-I used to walk like...
-Show me how.
So I was trying to, first,
I was like walking like this
and I heard a lot of go,
"You got it, girl."
And I was like, "Girl? Okay."
And then...
-No, no. Travolta kind of...
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Right?
-Yeah!
And that
got you the role?
-Thank you.
Huh?
-And that got you the role?
-No, they said
stop moving around so much.
Just say the lines.
-They said stop stop moving.
-Yeah, stop moving.
-Yeah.
How do you go
from "General Hospital"
to being in the Beach Boys?
-That's a good question.
-I mean, how do you get --
how do you play
with the Beach Boys?
-They were playing at
a baseball stadium in San Diego,
and my friend was in the band,
and he said, now when fun --
fun -- fun is over,
get back there.
And, you know, and they hang out
and then they go back
do an encore, then they leave.
So that's the only time
to meet them.
-If you want to meet them,
that's what you do.
-Right.
And so fun, fun, fun.
And I said, okay, where do I go?
And I walked down to the field,
and I was just
on "General Hospital"
and I heard all this screaming,
screaming.
I go, "What is that?"
And I go, "Oh, it's for me."
And all these cheerleaders
started chasing me
around the diamond
like an idiot.
I'm like, running the bases.
-They were running after you?
-Yeah.
-And they were
catching me
because I wasn't
a very good runner.
I had skinny legs,
these Jordache jeans,
my feathered, you know,
I look like I had
like a dead crow on my head.
And I'm running, and I look up,
I'm on the jumbotron,
and these girls.
And I run, run,
and there's a backstage,
then I ran in
and they slammed the door
and these girls were screaming.
I'm like [panting].
You know?
Like, all the Beach Boys
turned to look at me like,
"Who's that weirdo?"
You know?
And they, you know...
-And that's...
-Yeah, I was sweating.
-...That John Stamos from
"General Hospital" well.
-Yeah. My friend said
that's John Stamos.
Mike Love said, "Do girls scream
for him like that all the time?"
And he said, "Yeah."
He said, "Get him on stage."
-Is that right?
-And I played "Barbara Ann"
and that was -- that was it.
It was beautiful.
-I will say there's a funny,
funny, funny stories in here.
There's some cool stories just
for anyone that's growing up
and you go, yeah,
I can relate to that.
But then there's also
really touching stories.
I want to say the last chapter
is our friend,
you're a really good friend
and my good friend too,
but yours more than me.
But Bob Saget was your brother.
-Yeah.
-And that was our --
that was the last night
that I saw him.
And you never, you know, you go
to dinner, like,
you never think
it's going to be
the last time you see them,
the last picture.
And, Jimmy, he was like
everything
that I wanted Bob to be.
He was calm and, you know,
he listened and he was so sweet.
And we were there
with two girls,
and we we looked at each other
like, God,
what did we do
to get these beautiful wives?
And we were -- it was just
such a beautiful night.
And, you know, you're always
in a hurry in life, right?
Oh, I got to go do this,
I got to do that.
And, you know, we stayed.
And when something
like that happens,
you kind of want
to remember everything.
And what did we eat?
What did we do?
And we ordered some cake
and we had some coffee.
And we stayed longer than we
normally would have, you know?
And so if you have a chance,
if you're with someone you love,
someone you care about,
stay a little longer,
have the cake, have some coffee.
And it was a beautiful night.
And, you know,
it's hard without him.
[ Applause ]
-Thank you for doing it, buddy.
Thank you, bud.
Thank you for coming on.
Congratulations on the book.
We love you, buddy.
John Stamos.
"If You Would Have Told Me"
is available everywhere
right now.